let's talk the shocking truth about
long-term ozempicues according to an
interview with the creator of glp-1
Agnes medications Yen's host because L7
can often suppress food cravings or
hedonic hunger people kind of lose
pleasure in food and after two years
life becomes miserably boring the result
you get off the drug and you go back to
life as usual the medium time for
discontinuation was 13 months with 48
quitting by a year and 70 percent coming
off by two years and of course the
concern is what is going to happen when
people come off these drugs well the
data tells us that typically their blood
sugars Surge and they gain most of the
weight very quickly back so obviously
there's a vested interest in trying to
find that Goldilocks dose that can
suppress hunger and have the intended
effects without making you depressingly
bored but let me know in the comments
below if you guys have any more ozemic
questions